Qual a sua opinião sobre a dieta 100%
carnívora? Olha só, pessoal, hoje eu
quero bater um papo sério com vocês
sobre esse assunto que tá pegando fogo
nas redes sociais. Tem muita gente que
tem me perguntado sobre isso, sobre a
dieta 100% carnívora. Você sabe como é,
né? Ou penso que sabe como é. Todo mundo
quer saber se essa história de comer só
carne funciona mesmo ou se é mais uma
moda que vai passar. Então bora
destrinchar esse tema juntos, porque as
coisas não são bem preto no branco, como
alguns influenciadores por aí querem
fazer a gente acreditar. Primeiro vamos
entender direito o que que é essa tal de
dieta carnívora. Galera, essa dieta não
é uma dieta qualquer, é literalmente
comer apenas produtos de origem animal,
carne vermelha, frango, peixe, ovos,
víceras e às vezes laticínios. E olhe
lá, nada de frutinha, verdurinha,
grãozinho, nem mesmo aquela saladinha
básica. É proteína animal direto, sem
palavras e parece meio radical e vocês
vão ver que realmente pode ser. Agora,
antes de vocês acharem que eu vou sair
demonizando tudo, pense outra vez,
porque eu já fiz um vídeo sobre isso
anos atrás. Vamos olhar os dados
científicos mais recentes, o que a
ciência não mente. Gente, sai um estudo
bem interessante que foi feito com mais
de 2000.000 pessoas que seguiam essa
dieta há pelo menos 6 meses e pasme, os
resultados foram bem surpreendentes. A
maioria das pessoas relatou melhorias
significativas na saúde geral, no
bem-estar e pasm 95% disseram estar
satisfeitas com a dieta. Os caras
perderam o peso, o MVC médio caiu de 27
para 24 e muitos relataram melhoras em
condições inflamatórias e autoimunes.
Mas, ó, pessoal, vamos com calma que nem
tudo são flores. Quando a gente olha
pela perspectiva da abordagem funcional,
que é aquela visão mais integrativa que
eu tanto gosto de usar aqui no canal, as
coisas ficam mais complexas. Sim, é
verdade que eliminar alimentos
processados, açúcares e carboidratos
refinados pode trazer enormes
benefícios. Isso a gente já sabe faz
tempo. O problema é que quando você
corta tudo que é vegetal, você pode
estar perdendo nutrientes essenciais que
o seu corpo precisa para funcionar
redondinho. Eu digo, pode, não
necessariamente. Eu vou dar um exemplo
prático para vocês entenderem melhor.
Imaginem que o corpo de vocês é como um
carro de Fórmula 1. Ele precisa de
combustível de qualidade. A carne
fornece proteínas excepcionais,
vitaminas do complexo B, ferro na forma
M. que é super bem absorvido, zinco,
selênio, um monte de coisa boa, mas e a
vitamina C e o magnésio e as fibras que
alimentam as bactérias boas do
intestino. Esses nutrientes ficam meio
esquecidos na dieta carnívora. Um estudo
recentíssimo publicado em 2024 analisou
quatro versões diferentes na dieta
carnívora e descobriu que ela atende bem
as necessidades de alguns nutrientes,
como é o caso da riboflavina B2,
aneacina B3, fósforo, zinco, vitamina
B6, piridoxina B12, selena e vitamina A.
Bacana, não é? Mas aí que tá o puro do
gato. Ela fica deficiente em tiamina,
magnésio, cálcio, vitamina C, em alguns
casos ferro, folato, iodo e potássio. E
fibras, esquece, tem praticamente zero.
É aqui que entram as víceras, pessoal.
Esse é um ponto crucial que muita gente
esquece quando fala da dieta carnívora.
As víceras, fígado, rim, coração, basso,
pâncreas são literalmente os
multivitamínicos dessa dieta. Quando
você só come carne muscular, você tá
perdendo uma mina de ouro nutricional
que pode fazer toda a diferença pra sua
saúde nessa dieta. O fígado, por
exemplo, é uma bomba de nutrientes. 3
onças de fígado bovino contém quantidade
absurda de vitamina A, mais do que você
precisa pro dia inteiro. Também rico em
ferro, M, folato, vitaminas do complexo
B, especialmente B12, tem um pouquinho
de vitamina C. Então é praticamente um
suplemento nessa dieta. O coração também
é outro tesouro esquecido. Ele é rico em
com enzima Q10, que é fundamental pra
produção de energia celular e também de
saúde de cardiovascular. Os rins são
fonte excelente de selênio mineral
crucial para a função da tilodeide e
proteção contra o estresse oxitativo.
Também o basso ele fornece ferro em
abundância e vitamina B12. Já o cérebro,
eu sei que já dá um arpio só de pensar
de comer cérebro. É riquíssimo ômega3,
DHA, fósfolipídios e colesterol
essenciais paraa função cerebral. A
questão é que muita gente que adota a
dieta carnívoro fica só na carne de
músculo, bife, frango, peixe e ignora
completamente as vícias porque tem
nojinho. Aí depois reclama que tá
sentindo fraqueza, que os exames
mostraram deficiências. Gente, os nossos
ancestrais não desperdiçavam nada do
animal. Eles comiam desde o focinho até
o rabo e tinha motivo para isso. Agora
vamos falar de uma coisa que me chama
muito atenção nessa visão funcional, o
aspecto da inflamação e das doenças
autoimunes. Muita gente que adota essa
dieta carnívora relata
melhorias impressionantes em
artriteumatoide, lupus, doença de cromo,
colitecerativa e por aí vai. Isso faz
muito sentido do ponto de vista
científico. Quando você remove todos os
possíveis gatilhos alimentares, sejam
lectinas, oxalatos, saponinas, os
fodaps, você pode realmente dar uma
acalmada no sistema imune que tava meio
bagunçado, desregulado. Teve até um
estudo específico com 10 pacientes com
doença inflamatória intestinal que
melhoraram muito significativamente com
a dieta carnívora. Isso na faixa
cetogênica. Mas aqui entre nós, 10
pessoas é muito pouco para tirarmos
conclusões muito definitivas, não é?
Então a ciência precisa de números
maiores, estudos de mais longo prazo.
Está faltando em relação à dieta
carnífa, mas voltando às víceras, que
são fundamentais para quem quer fazer
essa dieta de forma mais inteligente. Se
você vai tentar carnívora, pelo amor de
Deus, inclua fígado pelo menos duas
vezes por semana. Uma porção de 100 g de
fígado bovino tem mais vitamina A do que
você consegue em quilos de cenoura. E o
ferro na forma M que o corpo absorve
muito melhor do que o ferro dos vegetais
vai tá nele. O rim, apesar de muita
gente torcer o nariz, acha muito
nojento, ele é rico em vitamina B12,
selênio e outros minerais essenciais. E
o coração, além da cozema que é 10, tem
vitaminas do complexo B e é uma fonte
interessante taurina que é aminoácido,
que é fundamental paraa função
cardiovascular. Sei que víceras não são
exatamente palatáveis pra maioria das
pessoas. A nossa cultura meio que perdeu
esse hábito, mas existem formas de
prepará-las que ficam bem mais
aceitáveis.
Patê de fígado com manteiga, por
exemplo, fica uma delícia. Coração
refogado com cebola lembra a carne seca.
E para quem realmente não consegue
encarar, hoje em dia existem suplementos
de víceras liofilizados em cápsulas que
podem quebrar um galho. Tem fornecedores
da Nova Zelândia.
E por falar em longo prazo, aí que mora
o perigo, galera. A dieta carnívora pode
funcionar como uma espécie de reset
temporário do sistema, principalmente
para quem já tem problemas inflamatórios
sérios.
Nesse caso, é como dar um respiro pro
organismo, eliminando todos os possíveis
vilões de uma vez. Mas manter isso para
sempre, aí a coisa fica complicada. Eu
vou ser bem claro com vocês. O que me
preocupa nesse caso, analisando pela
abordagem integrativa, é a ausência
total de diversidade alimentar. O nosso
microbioma
são as bactérias do bem que moram no
nosso intestino. Eles precisam de
variedade de fibras diferentes de
compostos bioativos que só encontramos
os vegetais. Então é como se vocês só
alimentassem os peixinhos do aquário com
tipo de ração. A vida toda. Vai
funcionar por um tempo, mas a longo
prazo pode dar rebu, pode dar problema.
E tem mais uma coisa que não posso
deixar passar. os níveis de colesterol
LDL. No estudo que eu mencionei, nesse
caso, LDL médio, os participantes
estavam em torno de 172, que tá elevado
segundo os padrões convencionais. Agora,
isso é bom ou ruim? Eu falei isso em
vídeos anteriores, checa no canal.
Depende do contexto. Se a pessoa tem HDL
alto, mas tem triglicérides baixos e
marcadores inflamatórios controlados,
esse LDL de 172 pode não ser nenhum
problema, mas é algo que precisa ser
monitorado de perto. Mesmo incluindo
víceras na dieta carnívoro, ainda
existem nutrientes que ficam
comprometidos. Por exemplo, a vitamina C
tem simgado. Mesmo o fígado tendo
pouquinho, pode não ser suficiente para
algumas pessoas. Pensa comigo, para ter
uma quantidade adequada de vitamina C
com consumo de více, você teria que
comer glândulas adrenais, rins ou
pâncreas. Quantas pessoas vocês acham
que estão dispostas a comer esse tipo de
coisa? Então, a vitamina E, os
antioxidantes vegetais, as fibras que
alimentam as bactérias boas, esses ficam
de fora mesmo. Então, uma pessoa em
dieta realmente carnívora, sem comer
nenhum vegetal, teria que
obrigatoriamente fazer a reposição da
vitamina E. Olha, se vocês me
perguntarem qual é que é a minha opinião
sincera baseada na minha experiência
clínica, na minha também na literatura
científica, eu diria o seguinte: a dieta
carnívora pode ser uma ferramenta
terapêutica interessante, sim,
especialmente para pessoas com condições
autoimunes severas ou inflamação crônica
que não respondem a outros tipos de
tratamentos, como uma espécie de dieta
de eliminação radical que funcionaria
por um período determinado. Mas antes
que alguém saia me atirando ou metendo
pau nos comentários, eu digo sim para
vocês, eu não sou contra essa dieta,
não. Eu só tô colocando a minha opinião.
E se alguém estiver se sentindo bem,
comendo essa dieta, seja por anos, estar
com os exames todos em dia, pessoal,
seja feliz, continue fazendo o que você
tá fazendo. Mas e isso é um mais bem
grande. Se alguém decidir tentar essa
abordagem, é muito importante comer as
víceras. Elas não são opcionais, elas
são obrigatórias.
É a diferença entre fazer uma dieta
carnívora nutricionalmente consciente e
fazer uma versão empobrecida que pode
levar a deficiências sérias. Como estilo
de vida permanente, aí eu fico com pé
atrás. A natureza nos deu uma variedade
incrível de alimentos por algum motivo.
Então, uma abordagem mais equilibrada
que inclua carne de qualidade, peixes,
ovos, víceras, quando possível, mas
também vegetais bem selecionados e
preparados de maneira adequada, me
parece muito mais sustentável e segura a
longo prazo. Eu sei que tem muita gente
fazendo dieta carnívora, mas tá comendo
vegetais. Aí não é bem dieta carnívora.
Mas de novo, se você tá assistindo esse
vídeo e faz a data carnívora e quer
continuar fazendo, contanto que seja
sendo acompanhado por um bom
profissional, continue fazendo, por
favor. Mas quem tá pensando em
experimentar, minha gente, dica:
primeiro, procurem a orientação
profissional qualificada. Segundo, se
decidirem tentar, não sejam só
carnívoros de bife, como um víceras na
rotina, mesmo que seja suplementos. E
pense também de comer alguns tipos de
vegetais específicos. Terceiro, façam
exames antes e depois para monitorar
como o corpo tá respondendo. E quarto,
considera a dieta carnív uma fase de
investigação e não como destino final. A
verdade que cada organismo é único e o
que funciona para uma pessoa pode não
funcionar para outra. É simples assim,
né, pessoal? A beleza da bordagem
funcional é justamente isso,
individualizar o tratamento, entender as
necessidades individuais de cada pessoa,
específicas de cada pessoa e usar as
ferramentas disponíveis, incluindo
mudanças alimentares de forma
inteligente e forma responsável. No
final das contas, pessoal, mais
importante é encontrarmos um caminho
alimentar que nos dê saúde, energia,
bem-estar e que seja sustentável ao
longo da vida. A dita carnívora pode ser
uma peça do quebra-cabeça para algumas
pessoas, especialmente quando bem
formulada com víceras. Não esquece das
víceras, mas dificilmente será a solução
completa para todo mundo. Muita gente
não vai nem pensar nisso. O segredo tá
em manter a mente aberta, estudar sempre
e principalmente escutar o próprio
corpo, que é o melhor médico que nós
temos. Boa sorte.
Compartilhe os vídeos, faça bem. A vida
de alguém pode mudar também no canal do
Tolém do Tar se envolva. Ah.